I've had four scenarios where doctors
told me I had to be on form of the rest
of my life and I'm not on either pill
and I've had two times where doctors
told me I had to have surgeries that I
haven't had and I just think I think
Western that is broken right for all the
good that those things have done in cute
cases if you're about to die there's
nothing better than Western medicine but
preventative it's horrific telling me
that in the early 60s diabetes didn't
exist in this country so we've gone from
a nation of priests kids that are making
64 ounce cokes at the 7-eleven their mom
doesn't know him better to tell him no
like I've literally seen it in rural
Illinois and this cups like this large
and it has a little bottom where it can
fit in the cup over the car it's like
how does that mom know we've now
exported that like 20 years ago nobody
was diabetic in China there are 400
million people that are pre-diabetic in
China in 20 years all those people are
now on diabetes medicine for the rest of
their life and instead of saying like
don't eat that don't drink the coke
don't go to McDonald's four times a week
but anytime you can get people off of
Pharma and on to some form of
plant-based medicine it's no different
than off of processed food and
plant-based food like Johnny for if you
confer you guys know sweet greens like
Johnny wants to be like the McDonald's
of healthy food boom and I think he can
and he's not all it's mostly plant-based
but you can get Fisher chicken there and
stuff and it's such an amazing company
he's got a great company culture and
just a really smart enlightened CEO
really wanting to move this forward
getting very involved in trying to
change policy around food and schools
make one look how corrupted the food
pyramid is done like they knew that
healthy fats were were safe for you and
were actually beneficial for you and the
70s and they paid off Harvard
researchers the sugar industry paid off
Harvard researchers to say that fat was
bad it's is like sent America down this
path for like 50 years that we're only
now saying like oh if I eat an avocado
it's not bad for me it's actually good
for me and and people on the coasts know
that but you go in the middle of America
and there's still there's still a lot of
women who
or men who think drinking a diet coke
and a power bar like Berzon from parsley
health tells that story of like I was in
Columbia med school and I thought I was
eating healthy because I had a diet coke
and a power bar for lunch it's like it's
insidious the marketing that gets woven
into your brain has really insidious and
then the other side of that you know are
we gonna look back in 2070 go again
Taoism back to 5,000 years old they
invented the whole concept of food as
medicine like they believed that there
were certain foods that you ate when you
had certain illnesses and there were
doctors who were experts at that like
I'm fairly like I know what my next 35
years is and it's like mainstream
wellness for the benefit of humanity
someone's opinion me contradict yours
what is my friend Alan it's all about
your perspective who are we and what is
the nature of this reality what's up
everyone welcome to simulation I'm your
host Don Saucon we are on-site at the
new West Summit the cannabis tech
conference we are now gonna be talking
with Jay fares hey Jay hello how are you
thanks for coming on the show thanks for
having me really appreciate it so pumped
for this founder of the wellness agency
dedicated to companies and talent in the
rapidly growing global four point two
trillion dollar wellness economy and
this is pushing back against the
feelings of big food Big Pharma and
Western medicine I'm so pumped to talk
about this this is obviously so massive
I'm Jayden but let's talk about your
journey first before we get to TWA who
are you what was your journey like how
did you get interested in this I
I know I know Kathryn Indy who works
with new West through she used to manage
bands that I had on a record label so I
had a record label called mammoth
records and we were the first indie 8
labeled I have two platinum acts and was
inside Atlantic for a while and had fun
with that but and then I was in media
and
Lionsgate the film and TV studio but I
started getting really my own journey
and it was watching my father's decline
and really bad advice from Western
medicine my brother had cancer really
bad advice from Western medicine in my
own journey where this is 10-15 years
ago but I was running very 35 miles a
week and and I had the best doctor for
four men in LA supposedly and he puts me
on cholesterol medicine and I'm like and
I do like 110 mile run a week probably
in total and I was like a week later two
weeks later I come back to him I was
like I feel like I'm gonna pull a muscle
on my calf and and he's like we'll
monitor it tell me you know next week I
go on the run sure enough I pull it I go
in and see him the next day and I was
like what do I do and and now that I've
studied functional medicine and Taoism
and the Taoist concepts of food as
medicine and a lot of there's ten basic
questions like are you stressed out are
you meditating are you drinking too much
booze are you eating whole foods are you
eating too much processed food too much
sugar such simple critical question
didn't ask me one of those and he goes I
was like what do I do and you think I
guess you got to stop running and I knew
nothing about wellness and I stood up I
laughed in his face and walked out the
door and that kind of began this journey
and then it was coinciding with my
father's decline and and just you know
his doctor was his best friend and we
hung out at the Country Club with and
you know so he thought he was getting in
was getting horrific advice so and
that's that's literally kind of I've had
to I've had four scenarios where doctors
told me I had to be on Pharma the rest
of my life and I'm not on either pill
and I've had two times where doctors
told me I had to have surgeries that I
haven't had and I just think I think
Western Matt is broken right for all the
good that those things have done in
acute cases if you're about to die
there's nothing better than Western
medicine but preventative it's horrific
Pharma whether it's the oxy story and
how there are a hundred thousand doctors
in jail I don't know like if you're
selling that [ __ ] on the street corner
and there are black oh there'd be a
hundred thousand people in jail for the
next 50 years
yeah let's sort of where where it began
I guess damn what and that this is such
a reoccurring theme of people that we
sit down with is that they experience
some sort of like a horrific like truth
about the ignorant of certain processes
that are happening in our world that are
literally impacting hundreds of
thousands of millions of people on on on
a yearly basis with their health
decisions and in this case it's like I'm
not sitting back anymore
my parents are affected my grandparents
affected my children are affected I'm
affected it's this it scales so much so
there's a friend of mine named Robin
Berzin it was an amazing company called
parsley health and that's mainstreaming
functional medicine on a subscription
model basis she announced yesterday the
close of her series be twenty six
million she was telling me that in the
early sixties diabetes didn't exist in
this country so we've gone from a nation
of prisoner drinking 64 ounce cokes at
the 7-eleven and their mom doesn't know
him better to tell him no like I've
literally seen it in rural Illinois and
this cups like this large and it has a
little bottom where it can fit in the
couple over the car and it's like how
does that mom not know we've now
exported that like 20 years ago nobody
was diabetic in China there are 400
million people that are pre-diabetic in
China in 20 years all those people are
now on diabetes medicine for the rest of
their life and instead of saying like
don't eat that don't drink the coke
don't go to McDonald's four times a week
so that's and in the journeys evolving
but they're there literally is immoral
III say like save the planet and a lot
of that plant-based thing even helps
their save our democracy and then it's
like mainstream wellness for the benefit
of humanity yeah yeah okay as we get
into this like solution of mainstream
wellness and all of the different
diverse areas that you want to target
with TWA let's also talk about a little
bit deeper on you just gave us this
example of these ridiculous whatever
they are like
those are ridiculous cups that fit yes
yeah the small car cart cup holder at
the bottom but then it's like at the top
all day there's so many examples that
the processed foods the factory farms
the antibiotic resistance the of the
amount of issues that are arising within
our bodies from just over overloading
the amount of food that we put in them
rather than doing interment fast yeah
yeah yeah yeah all these different types
of things all right what are the hidden
forces are the hidden agenda behind why
well missus soul docked I don't I think
wellness has taken off like the hair I
didn't get like what were those forces
do you think like what was propagating
the farm in that you mean you know this
pharma and the 20s you know they made a
racist on we Don Cannon and it's you
know it was the dirty Mexicans and all
that [ __ ] Ricki Lake did a really her
last doc we'd the people I thought
actually did a pretty cool visual
narrative of how early us Big Pharma
demonized the can of plant because they
didn't because it was solving problems
that they couldn't solve there's there's
evidence that the US government said we
don't have other solutions for this
let's not make that planet illegal and
they there were racist cartoons that
went into newspapers they turn public
opinion against it and they made it
illegal and it's been it's been
misinformation ever since and you can
damn well bet that everybody in pharma
is going to continue there's so many
like campaigns going on to demonize its
donuts to me anytime you can like again
I the the plan itself has so many
medicinal qualities to it which were
still there has to be a ton more
research but there's so much to learn
still and and any time I think you know
I'm working with a friend Bob forest and
and will collide them from Ojai
energetics on something because they
think they have something that helps
with opiate addiction and how do you
start to commercialize that but anytime
you can get people off of Pharma and on
to some form of plant based medicine
it's no different than
off of processed food and plant-based
food and it's I think there's just as
big an opportunity and just as big of a
sort of a parent imperative the the
pharma side of things where people go on
antibiotics like if you know much about
your gut biome it's they're now calling
it the second brain it's got as many
receptors as your brain does it
constantly talks to your brain all day
long and when you pump it full of
antibiotics of any kind
it completely [ __ ] that so if oxys up
here doing this to your like turning you
in an attic antibiotics they're like
ripping this up so and there are some
like I think leading edge probiotic
companies and things that again are
plant-based so or or have the essence of
that so I think that's where big
opportunity lies in a big need all right
so we're on this wellness awakening
that's happening cannabis is one of
these you give these examples like
moving away from you know the processed
foods into more like Whole Foods raw
foods this type of stuff yeah
also into like moving away from maybe
like a sedentary you know lifestyle into
a more active lifestyle there's all
these different like dichotomies and you
know moving yourself to the side of the
spectrum is where you moment to moment
just live better and live longer and all
stipe stuff how is TWA how do you guys
find where to allocate your time in the
wellness like what is how did you figure
out what to even target in the wellness
industry cuz it's just over fortunately
in Bucks there's so many opportunities I
forget this thesis that what the valley
was to tech 30 years ago Venice is
starting to become to wellness Venice
California
it's not you know it's Johnny from sweet
greens just raised at a billion dollar
valuation and smartypants vitamins which
is organic you know gummy bear vitamins
they're they're probably there are cats
with sea but there are these great
companies and these great founders and
it's kind of like when I used to have a
record label and I'd find a band that
was playing for 20 people in a basement
and figure out how to sell two million
albums I feel like I now find
entrepreneurs that I connect with it's
the same thing you see some
and you're like oh I can help them out
here here and here and add value and
you're like I believe in their mission
and if I can if I can help succeed in
that mission we're we're moving this the
mission of what we're trying to do
forward so it's part of its got part of
its instinct but it's also that I caught
the three years theory like Danny
Goldberg back in the day you started
he's like I didn't know if Nirvana was
good or not but like Silva told me that
that they were great and then you said
something about him and so on so so like
so then I believed it and and I you're
constantly like in this ecosystem you
constantly hear of new companies and and
sort of what we do with mammoths I
didn't want to have when I had mammoth
records the record label we had a lot of
different alternative subgenres with an
alternative and I kind of think we're
looking for the same kind of portfolio
approach for the companies we want to
work with so is there a bone broth
company we can blow up and now we're
doing I just hooked up will from Ojai
with this really dope bone broth company
called al Venice and they're gonna do a
CBD bone broth and it's like anytime we
can help with those kind of
collaborations that's what we love doing
okay okay I
we also factors so many incredible LA
and San Diego interviews we've been
talking to people they like the silicon
beach is the phrase of view I like that
a lot and it's true to blow-ups of these
billion dollar incredible evaluated
companies that are just like just health
and wellness yeah yeah just rocketing
that industry forward so it sounds like
there's actually quite a bit of like the
wellness agency focused on creating
value ads for companies that are in the
sector coming up in the sector you're
trying to figure out how to run like
network shares or like combining certain
things together like CBD bone broth like
it was really funny because like I'm
working with I'm working with oh hi al
Venice once I've just met her the
founder I love her she's amazing like
building a really cool company and she
likes she said it off the cuff and I was
like okay and then just it was a one
line text they had a phone call the next
day and it's at
so it's like so easy to move some of
that stuff along we just did an event
for another company called reset
bioscience which the founders like
really successful do that a Hong Kong
probably his fifth company and they've
got testing labs that are sort of
pharmaceutical grade testing on Hunt's
on the CBD side based out of Austin and
and the amount we did a sixty person
event for him at this vegan restaurant
in Venice called plant food and wine it
was like 20 that's a third of it was
talent twenty people a third of it was
money the third of those founders of
companies but there is just like this
super organic natural cross
collaboration of efforts and ideas and
and so that's I don't know that's what
we'd like doing it's fun yeah so then
where do you find the like how do you
guys identify the the people that are in
the wellness space that you guys want to
collaborate with it's just like now
especially it's just starting to come on
yeah yeah I've got I've got like
connections in England and they're like
you gotta meet with this company find
Nova they've just got all this money you
know it's 20 billion dollar Dutch
companies investing in them and it's the
mulberry leaf and it lowers your blood
sugar levels naturally and it's so it's
traditional Chinese medicine and the
mulberry leaf yeah yeah which it has all
these medicinal properties I love it
there's so many examples of that in
nature of ways that we've kind of just
like either indigenous people will still
know and the like the markets haven't
yeah now yet but there's so many of
those hidden things and even things that
endears people still don't know where
that archaeologically we still haven't
figured out that we knew a hundred
thousand years ago but yeah I love so
they're still the Dalit the Taoism like
going back to Taoism and there's there's
a woman named Zoe Gong who's she's 23
went to NYU but from Shanghai knows more
about traditional Chinese medicine than
any person I met and really wants to
contemporize TCM because there are so
many it's a 10 billion dollar market
globally but you
and sort of stuck in them it's like the
worst design and everything else
GCM yeah traditional Chinese medicine
and and there I think there are more and
more of these opportunities to where you
realize that traditional businesses are
failing us whether it's toothpaste
companies and they've got fluoride in it
and it leads to early stage Alzheimer's
and by you know let's let's look at
charcoal based to toothpaste companies
and the the next generation brands know
that anybody under 30 is only seeing
stuff on Instagram or other social
platforms and you've got crest over here
that's still probably doing TV
commercials and you know print
advertising and newspapers so that it's
like two different worlds
so the charcoal toothpaste companies are
on like tick-tocking Instagram and
pretty much pretty much yeah and it's
like that's the only world they know so
that's where they go and these guys and
I think sector after sector you were
seeing better for you alternatives sort
of come up so we're constantly looking
we have there's different organizations
that I'm a part of
but the funnel just keeps getting better
as our sort of reputation gets out there
yeah cool okay now you were giving us
all this like I just I just love this
point on the didn't these newer wellness
market that's our rub ting there's like
old dogs that are trying to like figure
out some of the young dog marketing
strategies and stuff and then there's
and then if they don't adapt I mean
these are this is what happens with the
the the goliaths and the David's and
like how does it how do Goliath fail
yeah and in a sense they shouldn't they
should know how to watch and adapt but
they don't necessarily have the right
they don't know they don't know how to
start new brands like it was funny like
when there's all these analogies to when
I had a record label to what I'm doing
now
and back then Atlantic did a G V with me
with mammoth records because they were
horrible they're great at selling 14
million hootie and the blowfish records
but like try and tell him to figure out
how to sell the first hundred thousand
to create the right buzz their cost per
unit sold was just through the
different totally different generation
but you see the same thing here where
you know Pepsi has a venture as a
corporate venture arm and they're
they're super aggressive nobody knows
about it because they know if their
names on it so they're buying healthy
food brands either buying majority stake
investing in nobody knows what's going
on they like one of the radar because
they know they're but they they're I
actually think that's good like they're
and then they're giving better
distribution weird word deepen talks
with Hershey's ventures her she has a
venture on now and it's like parents
don't want to just buy crappy effing
sugar for the kids anymore yeah so
they're all I actually don't think it's
bad like they know that yeah they know
that their name is such [ __ ] that for
some of these brands that they can't
attach themselves to it and and they've
they've gotten over that hook yeah if
yeah if fifty years ago it was okay to
to drink the big fatties of soda and it
was okay dude to drink fifty years ago
go back and look at it it's like the
chicken story if you ever seen the
chickens today and the chickens in the
60s they're literally twice as big
because we pump them so much follow so
many hormones and stuff coca-cola 50
years ago was served in eight ounce
bottles then I was twelve ounce then I
was sixteen then it was 32 so didn't you
used to be able to buy cokes and
literally the 8 ounce bottle back in the
60s yeah just that little tiny taste
yeah and then this is this is super
super interesting so now you have you
have what is like looking like goliaths
that are watching the wellness market
and in a sense if they have these
venture arms or these innovation
departments that are trying to like help
accelerate it cool oh great give them
give one of the wellness companies that
are doing great work Kumasi distribution
and stuff at the same time it's also
important to think of like well isn't it
in a sense aren't we trying to propagate
new code like it's Pepsi actually going
to be like yo
actually our like main thing like the
really sugary soda stuff is just
literally just not that great and maybe
like we should probably in the future
just you know help market people towards
new products that are not even that you
know how do they because are they really
thinking that because that's something
that the wellness agency and just like
in general wellness markets and modern
well-being markets are in a sense we
want to move away from old code and so
it seems like I think it's like a
company by company thing like Johnny I'm
sure you guys know sweet greens like
Johnny wants to be like the McDonald's
of healthy food boom and I think he and
and he's not all it's mostly plant-based
but you can get fish or chicken there
and stuff and it's such an amazing
company he's got a great company culture
and just a really smart enlightened CEO
really wanting to move this forward
getting very involved in trying to
change policy around food in schools I
mean I think about what I ate it it's I
ate garbage in school for like 12 years
just like the worst so that he's trying
to get involved in that I think is very
important and and there will be there
will be old lying companies that
reinvent themselves you know that who is
a Burger King that's now doing it
impossible so yeah it is I think where
you can get buy-in from these guys you
don't want to shunt it I think there
will be companies who surged past maybe
it's Johnny and sweet greens maybe with
somebody else and they'll coexist like
it's not like McDonald's is going to
disappear I don't make that case yeah
yeah I'm very interested in to learn
about what the maximal efficiency is of
the objective function of implementing
more modern well-being and wellness
technology into our world because I feel
like we always have these weird like
slip-ups that happen in these upses
looking back at it and I wonder how to
like eliminate those so that um like
like
instances of when you have like only
later on did we figure out blockchain
and cryptocurrencies right into
centralization technology after like
hundreds of years of using fiat
currencies and stuff like that and and
they just it's starting to make more
more and more sense like maybe if we
didn't have issues with you know with
migrating currencies across country
lines and stuff like that that it could
have unleashed a completely different
paradigm in the way that we engage with
each other creatively and ever all the
same stuff so that's just one like big
macro abstract one another one is like
the wall this one like why did we have
to endeavor into pumping chickens and
factory farms I still do we didn't need
to do that we are 50 years later kids in
2070 are gonna be like you guys are
[ __ ] insane that you slaughtered
billions of animals and now we grow
clean meat and bioreactors so that's the
kind of stuff like I don't want to have
ups moments where billions of animals
died or like that we had to have like
look out look out look out corrupted
there's a couple points I want to make
but look how corrupted the food pyramid
has gotten like they knew that healthy
fats were were safe for you and were
actually beneficial for you and the 70s
and they paid off Harvard researchers
the sugar industry paid off Harvard
researchers to say that fat was bad it's
it like sent America down this path for
like 50 years that we're only now saying
like oh if I eat an avocado it's not bad
for me it's actually good for me and and
people and the coasts know that but you
go in the middle of America and there's
still there's still a lot of women who
think or men who think drinking a diet
coke and a power bar like Berzon from
parsley health tells that story of like
I was in Columbia med school and I
thought I was eating healthy because I
had a diet coke and a power bar for
lunch it's like it's insidious the
marketing that gets woven into your
brain is really insidious and then the
other side of that you know are we going
to look back in 2070 go again
Taoism back
to 5,000 years old they invented the
whole concept of food as medicine like
they believed that there were certain
foods that you ate when you had certain
illnesses and there were doctors who
were experts at that
so China lost a lot of that knowledge
there now sort of reacquainting
themselves with it like if you go
through their history in the last 200
years it's just a lot of turmoil and
civil war after Civil War so it's sort
of trauma on type of generational trauma
but now they're starting to rediscover
wellness and for all of China's faults
president she gave a white paper on
wellness at the last five-year party
congress which blows my mind like yeah
would you ever imagine trump doing that
like it would never happen so i think
there is a real hunger and a thirst for
it and and you're right like if you know
that i even you know if you go to that
thing of save the planet save our
democracy mainstream wellness the the
impact of raising cattle versus cricket
protein or plant-based protein or it's
just so different on the impact on our
planet and i think we will be forced to
change it if we're gonna survive you
keep coming back to Taoism so I must
endeavor into this because I love Taoism
I love the way I think it's these these
teachings are probably some of the most
important in the world and yet they are
extremely buried in the noise of
civilization today so what has been your
relationship with Taoism and and how is
it also really closely like you said let
thy food be thy medicine um how how else
have have you really implemented that
into your own culture and into your
company's culture I don't I don't know
if it's it's maybe more of my ongoing
personal journey and I do go to Asia
four to six times a year we're doing a
lot of business over there again I don't
agree with a lot of stuff the Chinese
government's doing but from a business
standpoint there's five hundred million
and they're all you know 97% of them are
buying stuff on mobile commerce weekly
so I've given talks for d2c businesses
that if you're building a brand for the
future you're kind of a goofball for you
if you ignore what's going on in Asia
and I go over there and I think it's a
lot like here like I have friends who
even give me [ __ ] about doing business
in China and I was like we have cops you
shoot black people on the backs and we
have as many black people in jail as
they have Muslims and in that province
in jail so I don't think either
governments perfect I like ours a lot
better but I just I think it's my own
journey around meditation and what's
what's the right path for me and how do
I ground myself and by no means am I an
expert but I've enjoyed studying and I
enjoy continuing to learn and what does
it feel like to you what Dow isn't the
way what does the way feel like to you
no idea when I yeah I really don't know
I I have sort of a 10-point system for
me that grounds me but I don't I don't
know that that's the way I
I think more about my like true north in
my path and I know what I'm on it and I
know what I'm not like with me yeah
sometimes there's like did this is an
interesting point here then at those
bifurcating moments when it's like what
is my real North here and there's like
the decision that's being made for a lot
of people can be as simple as like you
know do I spend these couple hours as my
kid or do I work or do I you know go on
a hike or do I work or you know whatever
it is like things like that should I go
to this endeavor with this person or not
or yeah how do you feel into that to
those moments
I don't know if there's anything wrong
with going off your path just be able to
acknowledge to yourself that like you've
stepped off it but like this really like
I'm fairly like I know what my next 35
years is and it's like mainstreaming
wellness for the benefit of humanity and
if anything I can do they go on talent
side what we look at is people that we
think like a Zoi Gong that we think we
can turn into household names in the
next seven to ten years and help them
mainstream a business and a concept but
like you get stuff to like fight back
again just what we were talking about
earlier the McDonald's the Pepsi the
Pizza Huts have the marketing spend
those guys have in Middle America but
can you turn some can you find ten
people like a Dave Asprey with
bulletproof but even bigger like how do
you mainstream some of these people so
where their narrative and their
storytelling ability gets out there and
you and you get people to realize I came
maybe I shouldn't be on all these
prescription pills for the rest of my
life maybe I shouldn't be at McDonald's
all the time
maybe Canon and whatever form is right
for me has better medicinal properties
than then these antibiotics um yeah that
I'm getting jammed down by my face but
my doctor know what how does TWA make
the leap with getting those people
around the world to convert to modern
wellness styles I think it's happening I
mean I think there are a lot of
companies that are really taking off so
it's we're just trying to like I use
that analogy of what calm we did a long
time ago with SV angel in the valley and
he connected people he solve problems he
yeah and we're more consumer packaged
goods or products or not it's different
than him but if I walk down this if I
walk down a bikini in Venice or if I
hang out at erawan for two hours doing
meetings over coffees for founder's or
walk by me and I'm probably helping out
three of them and and sometimes it's a
contractual relationship and sometimes
it's just an introduction and but the
more we can feed that ecosystem I think
is
the right ethos to have and we're super
there's a company in love called
conscious city guide Milne a house and
she had this she created like the
definitive platform for conscious events
globally and she listed like eight
thousand of them in eighteen months just
sort of took on a life of its own
and she really wanted to you know at the
same time I was hanging out with girls
who runs AEG which is like Coachella and
stuff like that and repeating what
Rapinoe was looking out for a Live
Nation and those guys and their festival
side were trying to figure out how to
they kind of fix the food at the
festivals and they decided to bring in
art and then all they wanted to bring in
sort of conscious or wellness and
they're also looking at like what's a
wellness Coachella look like they're all
trying to like play with that game and
just connecting her with them and
Rapinoe fell in love with her and now
the sudden she's got the muscle to he
wants to build it into the culture of
his company he wants to look at these
events with her so there's so much
benefit that comes out of those two
knowing each other and helping each
other out but it's like she and I are
now working on the four other projects
so it's like by putting that deal in
place for her we helped the overall
ecosystem and and the more I think I
think we're at this phase of it or we're
Conway and SV angel twenty five years
ago so I think it's early days okay and
then what would you say that is the role
of things like artificial intelligence
in the modern wellness sector I've never
thought of it what do you think things
like maybe having a constant stream of
our biometrics be in lized and then
predict pathologies or like having AI
coach that just helps you on that
Northstar alignment on people to network
with or on food sleep exercise decisions
to make I think it's happening
reset bioscience which is CBD company we
work with I know is in meetings with one
of the big shoe manufacturers about just
that stuff where they'd be a bit of the
software to their hardware I think it's
great I always wonder if that wearable
technology is really gonna take off do
you think it is partly yes and also
partly the computer vision and ability
to get the biometric streams from things
like front-facing cameras it is also
just so I don't even need to wear some
so there's kind of like you probably
know way more about this than I do
well there's a big part of wellness as
well this is that because it's it's it's
being able to stream up a constant like
your heart's beating a hundred thousand
times but you're not measuring that
heart rate variability right now but it
can give you tremendous insights if you
were on stress levels and so much more
and same thing with with just like what
is actually happening inside your gut
right and your microbiome what's that
what's truly happening there it needs
samples overtime Debbie analyze them so
you have that little sensor on your
toilet after you poo that that takes
them it's that reads it right yeah so
and then that processes that data
compared to billions of others of humans
that as long as the companies aren't
siloing
the data as long as there's a way to be
able to take the 1 billion Chinese one
billion Africans 1 billion Europeans 1
billion line mares etc how do you and
then be able to 1 billion Indians and be
able to actually synthesize those data
to find patterns mm-hmm and then to be
able to say that yeah I love all this
you know I'm learning from you right now
how far out is that there's companies
that are already on the toilet sensors
um there's companies that are already so
you submit your own
fecal samples into them and that they
run like meta transcriptomic analysis of
your microbiome all of those complex
organisms they're in there and then
there's even they even go as far as to
say things like uh actually there is no
such thing as a universally healthy food
which I thought was like whoa like as in
like spinach is not good for absolutely
everywhere avocados are not absolutely
good for
everyone so as in like actually it's
really important for you to like
constantly be checking in with what's
going on in there because then there
could be literally an overtime dynamic
process that is so so the amount of time
right now that we spent on going like
what should we eat you know and like and
like going versus just maybe in the
future and I don't know how people
necessarily feel about this yet but like
literally the little like robot is like
you know pulling it up through the door
it's like oh here's that you know that
little snack at you know five o'clock
for you and it's already an analysis of
what I have to be eating it's like some
know some spinach with like whatever
raspberry vinaigrette or whatever
walnuts you know I'm just like whatever
number it is you know and so these are
kind of the ideas of the future that
some people are really interested in
other people are like I want my free
choice and what I do and other people
are like no AI coach it you know I I
guess I love all that I feel like
there's so much basic stuff to do of
getting people off McDonald's and Pepsi
on the real food which is but it goes to
the the can aside of it too it's like
anytime you can get people into this
plant and off Pharma in all that its
manifestations I think there's a benefit
I think everything you're saying is
right I a lot of what we talk about like
I know there's this world in Venice and
people are super conscious of it they're
not in most of the country and how what
are the steps like we succeed if we
mainstream this yeah so how do I make
the cool band sell two million records
instead of twenty thousand that was
always the high I got and I want to do
the same thing I see but it's true it's
like that's what I believe I like
finding entrepreneurs and it's like holy
[ __ ] this is Game Change if we do this
you know it's a company we're working
now and they think they have a solution
to the opiate crisis and that's CBD
based and if that's true there's 20
million people that are heroin addicts
now so that's the kind of [ __ ] we want
to try and do yes I love everything
you're talking
yeah but how quickly can that stuff be
mainstreamed and does that does that
solve some of those other problems where
people think they have to be on five
prescription meds for that it's a
[ __ ] scam like Pharma once I caught
the subscription model of pills they
want you buying stuff every month and
the insurance company's in on it and
like it's so broken yeah I think we're
looking at a pretty classical
distribution right now where you have
like on one of the very progressive tail
ends you have the hyper the conscious
eaters conscious exercisers whatever all
that stuff and then you got like the AI
is kicking and on on on hopefully being
able to democratize some of that stuff
to the people that may be not as aware
of it and maybe there's creative
storytelling is such a big thing and
that's where what you were just talking
about I think that's potentially another
field where content being king maybe
there's a way to leverage some of the
computational capacities and
distributing the stories more
effectively to people that are on
opiates or that are that are eating
processed foods a couple times a week
you know things like that so that's
where I see a lot and also it's a
geopolitical thing because there's a lot
of people around the world that are also
not necessarily on for the conscious
culture because there was a a Western
culture got spread in the sense of the
the sugary drinks and the and the fast
foods and stuff and then so now there's
a whole correction that is happening in
those areas as well and there's the
traditional change medicine you're
talking about is well there's still so
much discovery rediscovery in a sense to
be made there so those things kind of
like coalesce into what modern
well-being seems to be our key arcing
into and like maybe if you spent much
time in Europe like on this thing you're
looking at canna or wellness or any of
this stuff I'm amazed in Europe you have
there's so many
preservatives chemicals things that
aren't allowed in food or products and
Europe that we owe that our FDA allows
in that's pretty mind-blowing the number
of products and and the research that
they're just looking at that we just
ignore but the flip side of that is it
feeI was just over there on a on a deal
and they feel on the canner side of
stuff they feel five years behind
probably like they're very curious they
see what's going on they see the size of
the market going 1 billion 20 billion 50
billion you know the next decade but but
they're so far behind in their knowledge
which I don't know it's more an
observation I find it interesting yeah
yeah whoa
that's another interesting one where
different countries have different
combinatorial frameworks that they've
put up protocols for what they allow in
to their food systems or what they allow
into their media in some ways as well
and so then how does that work with
catalyzing the awakening of wellness and
so which ones are more optimal which
ones are more effective is a question
that we love asking and talking about
because when you get the ability to run
so many experiments you want to then
analyze which ones are producing the
most efficient wellness augmentation yes
do you have you studied permaculture
much I know I'm going all over the map
this is great that's what the permit
hold of you there's this amazing book
called kiss the ground and it's Ryland
from Cafe Gratitude down he opened the
Venice one and his family started it up
here back in the day the idea that we
can heal the planet by a type of farming
and the the French government has like
the head of Agriculture for the French
government has fully endorsed this stuff
and the science is fully there but it's
the same thing it's like can we have the
collective will to all get behind this
and embrace it
vs season
you know points of view on how we're
going to farm and in America and it's it
it it's very much the Diamandis mindset
of like the solutions are there it's
more about do we have the willpower to
that we can pull the sort of poison out
of the air and heal our planet and that
ability is we can do it through farming
if we all got behind this so but that
books fascinating might be read why we
sleep Matt Walker is incredible hidden
it yeah yeah he's on fire yeah I love
the foundation he's like I thought it
was three things I thought it was food
exercise and sleep and now those are the
three legs of the stool but it's the
foundation that everything's built on
here and it's like that idea of like if
you're a real entrepreneur you're up at
6:00 a.m. and it's like no sleep in if
you need to because you're gonna make
better creative decisions you'll be less
stressed off stressed out yeah yeah it's
a phenomenal book have you had him on we
spoke with him yeah he's great yeah but
it like to me that's I've easily told a
hundred people if they read one book
this year that's the book they have to
read yeah it just gives you another
whole of their perspective into
understanding cognition as well because
you it totally makes sense that if
you're up sixteen hours that those eight
hours are literally meant for those what
you took in a sensory inputs those 16
hours for them to basically add into the
database of your previous 27 years of
life and that's how it just continues
working that's how you're it's just it's
just inputs in into storage while you
sleep you got to store it so that you
it's it's while that that's your take
like my takeaway from that was more like
because I was always focused on dollars
so there should wellness of like don't
drink Coke and actually
and meditate and drink enough water and
it's like no if people aren't getting
enough sleep it doesn't matter if
they're doing if they're getting shitty
sleep it doesn't matter what all these
other things and that's that he it's you
think I thought it was gonna be of the
driest book in the world and I found it
fascinating to read like really fun to
read and he goes through it step by step
but it whether it's creativity or
totally just everything it really does
impact she'll pretty fascinating yeah
yeah I want to hit two questions that we
typically ask her guests at the end of
every single show first one is are we in
a simulation I don't know what do you
think
I have no idea
how often do you get that answer well
you know I don't know decent okay yeah
we love the wide-ranging answers on that
that's very interesting
yeah some people come in like hard yes
some people come in hard no some people
yeah it's pretty interesting and then
what do you think is the most beautiful
thing in the world the journey of life
we can get the carve out your own vision
and then go make it happen the ability
to continue to learn the adventure that
we get to embark on yeah thank you very
much thank you for having my grandma
loved it I love that thank you thank you
thanks for all your great work thanks
everyone for tuning in or didn't
appreciate it we'd love to hear our
thoughts in the comments below on the
episode let us know what you think and
check out the links in the bio below
today's work to the Wellness agency
check out all the links in the bio to
that also two new West Summit support
the artists the entrepreneurs the
organization's the leaders around the
world that you believe and support them
and help them grow you can find
simulations links below to our show and
go and build the future everyone
manifests your dreams into the world you
love you very much thank you for tuning
in and we will see you soon thanks good
job Jay thank you said that was super
fun loved it awesome
[Music]
you